Good afternoon, everyone, and a warm welcome
to the first of our clinical trials plenary
sessions this afternoon.
This is the first of four clinical trial plenaries over the course of the next
three days at AACR, and we have four
really exciting clinical trials presentations this afternoon.
My name is Dr. Jayesh Desai. I'm a medical oncologist at the Peter MacCallum
Cancer Center in Melbourne, Australia.
That's not my photo.
And I would like to begin the session now.
Good afternoon, everyone. Welcome again. It's a pleasure to be here.
My name is Eileen O'Reilly. I'm a GI medical oncologist focused
on pancreas and hepatobiliary malignancies in early and mid and
late-phase drug development.
So it'll be great to get us started today.
We're going to start with the theme of RAS for the first two talks, and it's
a pleasure to introduce Dr. Byung Chul Cho from Yonsei
Medical Center in Korea, and he's going to speak to us on the
safety and efficacy of elacrasib,
D-3S001, a next-generation
GDP-bound KRAS G12C inhibitor as
monotherapy in advanced non-small cell lung cancer previously
treated with or without a KRAS G12C inhibitor.
And these are results from a Phase I/II study. Thank you.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
First of all, I would like to thank
scientific committee for inviting this abstract to
this plenary session. On behalf of my co-investigator,
it is my great honor to present results from Phase I/II
study evaluating safety and efficacy of
elacrasib, formerly known as
D-3S001, a next-generation GDP-bound KRAS
G12C inhibitor in advanced NLCLC.
These are my disclosures.
Elacrasib is a CNS-penetrable next generation
KRAS G12C inhibitor designed to maximize target
engagement and outpace growth factor-stimulated
GDP and GTP exchange.
Preclinically, elacrasib effectively
deplete active KRAS even in the presence of growth factor
stimulation like EGF and EGF, and it
demonstrated robust preclinical activity in
sorafenib-resistant PDX model harboring
RTK-driven resistance and KRAS
G12C-amplified xenograft model.
Clinically, elacrasib exhibited
promising efficacy across different tumor type in an ongoing
Phase I/II trial.
Among G12C inhibitor-naive patients, confirmed
objective response rate was seventy-three point five percent
with ORR approaching nearly 90% in
colorectal cancer.
Among G12C inhibitor-pretreated NLCLC, objective
response rate was 30% with 80% disease
control rate.
These findings were independently reported in "Cancer
Discovery" and "Nature Medicine".
Today, we present the full expansion data of Phase
I/II trial in second-line plus KRAS G12C mutant
NLCLC, naive and refractory
KRAS G12C inhibitor.
Elacrasib showed favorable pharmacokinetic
profile with a terminal half-life of approximately eight
hours supporting once daily dosing.
Exposure increases dose-dependently without
accumulation. Bioavailability increased from two
hundred milligram to four hundred milligram.
Six hundred milligram QD achieved four times higher
trough concentration than required for complete target
inhibition in the cell and exceeds the exposure than required
for complete tumor regression in the xenograft model.
Study consists of Phase I dose escalation, followed
by Phase II expansion.
In Phase I part,
patient with locally advanced metastatic KRAS G12C
mutant solid tumors were treated across multiple dose
level to evaluate tolerability, safety, and
RP2D. Notably, no DLT was observed,
and MTD was not reached, and six hundred
milligram QD was selected as RP2D.
In Phase II part, we enrolled both G12C
inhibitor-naive and refractory NLCLC population.
For G12C inhibitor-refractory population, patients
were required to receive only one
prior G12C inhibitor treatment and to achieve best
response of PR or CR regardless of treatment
duration or stable disease for at least six months.
This enabled focused evaluation in a
clinically meaningful resistant population.
Here we summarize the patient demographics.
Patients were in their 60s, predominantly male,
were enrolled globally, about half from China.
Majority of patient had ECOG PS1. Disease burden
was substantial. About 20% of patient had
brain or liver metastasis, and some of
diameter of baseline target lesion
was over, uh, forty millimeter in about
60% of patients.Coming to the safety,
treatment was well-tolerated, with most adverse events being
manageable in this heavily pretreated population.
Grade 3 or higher TRAE occurred in about
14 to 16% of patients. Serious
TRAE were infrequent, and importantly, there was
no Grade 5 adverse event. TRAE leading
to discontinuation occurred in only 1% to
3% of patients, and those modifications were
infrequent and mainly driven by gastrointestinal events.
Here we summarize the safety profile of G12C
inhibitor-naïve and refractory population.
Most common TRAE were nausea, diarrhea,
vomiting, but predominantly Grade 1.
Importantly, any Grade AST/ALT
elevation occurred in about 10% of patients, with the
majority being Grade 1. There was a single
episode of Grade 3 AST/ALT elevation observed in the
same patients in the G12C inhibitor-naïve cohort.
Here we summarize the prior systemic therapy in
G12C inhibitor-naïve population.
Overall, this is a clearly heavily pretreated population
with approximately 40% of patients
receiving two or more lines of prior therapy,
and above 80% of patients had received
both CPI and platinum-based chemotherapy, and
time from last checkpoint inhibitor was less than
60 days in about 40% of patients.
Now looking at the efficacy of elacestrant in second-line
plus G12C inhibitor-naïve NRCLC
population. You can see the waterfall plot.
Vast majority of patients showed significant tumor
shrinkage as you can see here. Confirmed objective response rate
was 53.6% in all dose,
and at six milligram QD dose confirmed objective response
rate was 52.9%, including one
CR and nearly 100% disease control
rate.
Here we summarize the spider and swimmer plot, and
then you can see response to elacestrant was rapid,
deep and durable. Among 50 responders,
70% of patients had first response at
week six, and 32.6%
continue study treatment.
Coming to the duration of response in G12C
inhibitor-naïve population, median DOR was
14.9 months in all dose and
16.5 months in 600 milligram
QD dose. Here we summarize the progression-free survival in
G12C-naïve population, and median PFS
was 9.4 months in all dose and
12.2 months in
600 milligram dose. With a median follow-up of
12.2 months, median OS was not mature, with a
12-month OS rate being 68% and
72% in all dose and 600 milligram dose
respectively.
Next, quickly switching gear to G12C inhibitor refractory
setting. Here we summarize the prior systemic therapy in
second-line plus NRCLC.
About half of patients had received at least
three prior line of therapy, and about
90% of patients had received checkpoint inhibitor and platinum-based
chemotherapy. Regarding prior G12C
inhibitor,
about 50% of patients had received sotorasib
or adagrasib, and two patients had received next
generation G12C inhibitor such as carderasib or
olaparib. Time from prior G12C inhibitor
was within 60 days in 50% of patients.
Duration of prior G12C inhibitor was longer than
six months in 75% of patients. Majority
of patients discontinued treatment due to progressive disease,
and best response to prior G12C inhibitor was
PR or SD in about 80% of patients.
Together, these patients derived initial clinical
benefit but ultimately developed resistance,
representing a truly refractory population with
clear unmet medical need.
So in this refractory population, you can see
in this waterfall plot, majority of patients showed tumor
shrinkage, and
32.3% of patients achieved
partial response with 25% confirmed
partial response and nearly 84% disease
control rate.
These spider and swimmer plot provide additional insight
into the depth and durability of response to
elacestrant in this refractory population.
Among 10 responders, 50% had first response
at week six, and 25% of patients had
ongoing study treatment, suggesting durability of
treatment in this refractory population.
Here we summarize the duration of response and PFS.
Median duration of response was 15.6 months,
and median PFS was 8.1 months. With a median
follow-up of 12.2 months, median OS was not
matured with 12 months OS rate
of being
71%.So this is the representative case
of heavily treated G12C inhibitor-naive NRCLC.
This 67-year-old male had progressed after
first-line chemoimmunotherapy followed by docetaxel.
Upon treatment of elacestrant,
the patient achieved a confirmed partial response evident as
early as 1.9 months with marked and rapid
tumor shrinkage. The tumor response was not only
deep but also durable, with the patient remaining on
treatment for more than two years.
This case highlights the CNS activity of
elacestrant in G12C inhibitor-refractory
patient with untreated brain metastasis.
This 55-year-old patient had progressed
on KRAS
G12C-based combination and progressed
including in the CNS progression,
followed by rapid failure
on chemoimmunotherapy.
Elacestrant produced visible shrinkage
in the CNS with a continued improvement
at the later time point. The
patient was on the treatment for nearly 10
months.
So here we summarize the rapid and deep
molecular response in ctDNA
G12C-positive patient. First,
baseline KRAS G12C was detected in
about 70% of patients in both cohorts.
Notably,
we observed rapid and deep KRAS G12C PAF
reduction, observed as early as cycle one,
day eight, indicating rapid and potent
target engagement of elacestrant.
Second, high rate of molecular response and complete clearance
were observed in both G12C inhibitor-naive and refractory
cohort, and this complete
ctDNA clearance was strongly associated with
radiologic response.
So here we
summarize the KRAS G12C dynamic by
ctDNA and clinical response. First, a patient with
a detectable baseline KRAS G12C showed higher
objective response rate compared to those without detectable
KRAS G12C. And this suggests
that baseline molecular
detectability may enable responder.
More importantly, among baseline ctDNA KRAS
G12C positive patients, complete KRAS
G12C PAF clearance during treatment was
associated with markedly higher response rate.
This suggests the potential role of ctDNA in on-treatment
response monitoring.
This slide summarizes the baseline
SDK11 or KEAP1 co-mutation,
and its relationship with the clinical response.
So in our study, SK11 and
KEAP1 alteration were found in about 50% of
patients. And as we all know, this genomic
alteration drive tumor biology through a pathway
largely independent of KRAS inhibition and are
typically associated with poor clinical outcome.
Despite this, elacestrant showed comparable
efficacy regardless of
SDK11 or KEAP1 genomic alteration.
Objective response rate was 76% in
patients without alteration compared to 55%
in patient with genomic alteration.
Now here we summarize the baseline gene
alteration profile in G12C inhibitor-refractory cohort by
ctDNA analysis. Amongst 31 analyzed
patients, about 70% of patients had a
detectable KRAS G12C at baseline,
confirming ongoing KRAS dependency even
after a prior G12C inhibitor treatment.
Notably, 16% of patients had KRAS
amplification, a well-known resistant mechanism to
G12C inhibitor. In addition, a broad range
of alterations such as RTK, PI3K, MAP
kinase, and other pathway alterations were observed, highlighting the
molecular heterogeneity and complexity of this
population.
Here
we show the efficacy of elacestrant in G12C
inhibitor-refractory patient with KRAS amplification.
As you can see here, 60% of patients achieved confirmed partial
response with 100% disease control rate and
40% continued study treatment, and
67% of patients achieved partial response
six weeks after treatment.
Regarding molecular response, 60% of
patients achieved molecular response as early as cycle one, day
eight, and then complete G12C clearance at
cycle four, day one. And this indicates
elacestrant's complete and fast target engagement may
address resistance mediated by KRAS amplification.
Now we show acquired genomic alteration
in G12C inhibitor-naive patients.
Paired
baseline and EOT ctDNA analysis was performed in
18 patients with PFS longer than three
months. And at EOT,
no KRAS amplification was detected in
G12C inhibitor-naive cohort. This implies
that elacestrant's complete and rapid target engagement
may reduce the
emergence of KRAS amplification as acquired resistance
mechanism and correlate with its
clinical efficacy in this patient population.So in
conclusion, elacridar monotherapy demonstrated
robust and durable efficacy in G12C naive
and G12C inhibitor refractory population at RP2d.
Objective response rate was 58.8%,
and median PFS was 12.2 months. Amongst
G12C inhibitor refractory population, objective response rate
was 32% with a median PFS of
8.1 months. Importantly, in five patients with
KRAS amplification, ORR was 60%.
The safety profile of elacridar remains favorable and
consistent with phase one dose escalation.
We observed this ctDNA of deep and
rapid molecular response without the emergence of KRAS amplification,
which correlate with the differentiated
mechanism of action of elacridar.
Based on this promising efficacy and safety data,
elacridar monotherapy received BTD and fast track
designation in NLCLC,
which warrants pivotal trial of monotherapy in
combination with checkpoint inhibitor in frontline setting.
Lastly, we thank all patients and the family, clinical trial
staff that participate in this trial. Thank you for your attention.
Thank you very much, Dr Chou. And now to put the
increasingly complex and differentiated field of
G12C inhibitors in non-small cell lung cancer, it's
an honor to invite Dr Sacher, who's going to speak to us on this
topic.
Thank you.
Thank you for the kind introduction, and I would like to thank the organizing
committee for the invitation to discuss this abstract.
These are my disclosures.
KRAS constitutes a challenging target requiring an entirely new
therapeutic paradigm. We know that it is a difficult to target
GTPase. It has a complex downstream signaling
pathway with associated tendency towards compensatory feedback and is
also associated with a unique immunobiology.
Newly developed KRAS inhibitor classes each have complex and distinct
mechanisms, including both the KRAS G12C off inhibitors, which we
will focus on today, as well as the newer tricomplex and dual state
KRAS G12C on inhibitors.
KRAS G12C off inhibitors covalently bind the switch II binding
pocket of GDP bound KRAS G12C, thus locking it
into its inactive state. There are multiple agents in this drug
class, each utilizing a similar mechanism but exhibiting variable
potency, variable response rate, as well as variable toxicity.
Indeed, there are a large number of such off inhibitors approved during
development, including the original, arguably less potent
sotorasib and adagrasib, as well as newer agents like
divorasib, alomorasib, calderasib, elacridar, and
many others.
Sotorasib was the original KRAS G12C off inhibitor
and in many ways set the tone for the field.
The best data for sotorasib come from the CodeBreaK 200 randomized study of
sotorasib versus docetaxel in the later line setting in non-small cell lung
cancer. Here we saw a modest but real response rate with
sotorasib of 28.1%. And although sotorasib
improved progression-free survival in this later line population, it did
not significantly change overall survival.
In contrast, newer and more potent inhibitors like divorasib
have exhibited still modest but improved response rates.
Here you can see from an early phase study of divorasib a response rate of
53.4% and a more durable PFS at
13.1 months.
And we are looking forward to ongoing studies comparing divorasib to sotorasib and
adagrasib in the later line setting.
As you probably gathered, primary and acquired resistance are the key challenges
for KRAS G12C off inhibitors, where we see these modest response
rates. We are still elucidating these mechanisms of resistance,
but key mechanisms include compensatory pathway activation and
overdrive. Essentially anything that keeps KRAS in its active
GTP-bound state will resist binding to a GDP-based inhibitor.
As well as other mechanisms like KRAS amplification, alternative KRAS
variants, drug binding pocket alterations, bypass pathway
alterations, and even histologic transformation.
We've also come to note that KRAS G12C off inhibitors are associated
with unique mechanisms of toxicity, notably immune-mediated
hepatitis, which occurs oddly only in PD-1 experienced
patients. We've encountered this with the original inhibitors like
sotorasib, and indeed, in the case of sotorasib, the degree of
autoimmune hepatitis experienced precluded combinations with
immunotherapy. We've also seen it with newer inhibitors like divorasib
and others.
This brings me to the key question that I always ask myself whenever I see data on
a new KRAS G12C inhibitor in this very crowded space.
And that question really is: Does the world need another KRAS G12C
off inhibitor?
But I always approach this question fairly and logically, and I tend to apply the
same rubric for evaluating novel inhibitors.
Specifically, I like to think carefully about the frequency of primary resistance
as well as the potency of the inhibitor, and this usually comes through in the
response rate. I like to think carefully about the mechanism as well as the
speed of acquired resistance that we see in these patients, which you can usually
divine from the PFS. And then I look closely at
toxicity barriers, especially autoimmune hepatitis, as well as the
ability of a new agent to overcome acquired resistance to other agents
and its activity in difficult to treat subsets, namely STK11,
KEAP1, and PDL1 negative patients.
Truly, the utility of a new KRAS G12C inhibitor hinges on these
parameters, both when we think about it as a more optimal monotherapy as
well as a foundation for future combination therapy.We
saw data today on elacrasib from an early phase study looking at both
KRAS G12C inhibitor naive and refractory non-small cell lung
cancer patients.
And looking first at the toxicity of this drug, we did see that treatment
discontinuation due to toxicity was rare in this study.
However, dose interruption and dose reduction were more common.
The primary toxicity that we saw from elacrasib was GI in
nature, and the majority of these cases were Grade 1 or
Grade 2. There was a signal of autoimmune hepatitis consistent with
this class of drugs. The frequency
was relatively low, and most of these cases were low grade.
However, it is important to note in this study that 10% of patients had
not had a previous checkpoint inhibitor, and the
majority of patients were more than 60 days out from their previous checkpoint
inhibitor, which means that the study may underestimate the actual risk
of autoimmune hepatitis, given that both of these would reduce the frequency
of this event in this population.
Turning now to efficacy in the G12C naive population, we
saw a favorable response rate compared to other potent inhibitors in this field
with a response rate of 53.6% across dose levels
and 52.9% at the Phase 2 dose.
Progression-free survival was 9.4 months across dose levels and
12.2 at the Phase 2 dose.
Looking at the G12C refractory cohort, before we look at the data, it's
important to note that the majority of these patients received previous,
older, less potent inhibitors, and most patients, or at least half of
patients, were more than 60 days out from their previous inhibitor.
This raises the question of how many of these responses are true
circumvention of an acquired resistance mechanism versus just
reresponse in a patient where sensitive clones have grown out again
after holding a previous G12C inhibitor.
Nonetheless, with those caveats, we did see a response rate of
25.8% in this difficult-to-treat population
and a median PFS of 8.1 months.
Last but not least, we also saw a signal of potential activity amongst more
difficult to treat subsets like STK11 and KEAP1 co-mutated patients.
And thus to return to our key performance measures, I think it's clear that
elacrasib demonstrates a favorable response rate relative to other highly potent
inhibitors in this setting. We also saw
evidence of durable PFS.
There is still a signal of autoimmune hepatitis consistent with the field, and this
will need to be watched carefully as we should watch with all KRAS G12C off
inhibitors.
And we did see the ability, potentially with the caveats that I mentioned, of
elacrasib to overcome acquired resistance to other agents, as well as
activity in difficult-to-treat subsets.
Thus, the early-phase data here do support elacrasib as a promising KRAS
G12C off inhibitor as monotherapy with potential for combination
therapy in the future. That being said, elacrasib is not
emerging into the field in a vacuum.
It is emerging late into an extremely crowded field.
The reality is that the modest clinical activity of existing KRAS G12C off
inhibitor monotherapy has led to a rapid push to develop combination
strategies. Indeed, KRAS G12C and immunotherapy
strategies are already well along in development, particularly in the
frontline setting in metastatic non-small cell lung cancer.
We've also seen EGFR antibody-based combinations, which were pioneered in
colorectal cancer, now begin to transit into the frontline setting in
non-small cell lung cancer, as well as many other novel combination strategies
in development.
There are also newer efforts to develop KRAS on, pan-KRAS, and RAS
inhibitors that are extremely promising in terms of mechanism and property
relative to the older off inhibitors.
To quickly touch on some recent data, we've seen data presented on
calderacib plus pembrolizumab in PD-L1 positive KRAS G12C mutant
metastatic non-small cell lung cancer recently.
Important highlights include that the response rate amongst PD-L1 high patients
with this combination was 87%, and the PFS in this
subset of PD-L1 high patients has not yet been reached.
In tandem, we've seen the rise of KRAS G12C on tri-complex
inhibitors, including eloronrasib, which work on the on state
via formation of an inhibitory tri-complex.
And indeed, we've seen interesting early data on eloronrasib in
KRAS G12C off acquired resistance, where a response rate of
42% has been observed in a small cohort of patients.
And interestingly, we have not seen the same signal of autoimmune
hepatitis with this newer class of drugs.
We've also seen the rise and proliferation of
direct KRAS G12C on and pan-KRAS inhibitors utilizing a
newer dual state targeting mechanism, which allows for simultaneous
binding to both the inactive and active state of KRAS.
This approach allows for rapid blockade of KRAS signaling in both states
and offers the potential to overcome pathway overdrive, as well as many of the
common mechanisms of primary resistance that we postulate have
occurred in KRAS G12C off inhibitors.
And again, there are many agents rapidly in development utilizing this
mechanism.
So to close, I would like to envision the future of KRAS G12C in non-small cell
lung cancer. It's clear the KRAS G12C off inhibitors have
revolutionized the field. Monotherapy has entered standard of care, and it
continues to be optimized. Combinations are under intense
investigation and have significant lead time over newer
agents. All that being said, we really do need greater
understanding of the mechanisms of primary and acquired resistance, as well as
approaches to circumvent them, and greater understanding of the peculiar
autoimmune toxicity associated with these drugs to guide
rational development.Novel KRAS G12C on
tri-complex and dual state inhibitors may overcome the fundamental limits of
off inhibitors. We've seen evidence of activity in primary and acquired
resistance to KRAS G12C off inhibitors.
There's also potential for improved combinability with immunotherapy and other drug
classes. And although the data for these agents remain early, they have
great potential to disrupt the current off inhibitor paradigm.
And thus, in conclusion, if you came to this talk hoping that I would give you
clear direction on which approach or strategy was going to win in this field, I
unfortunately will have to disappoint you.
Truly, I think the only thing we can say at this point is that it's still anyone's
game. Thank you.
Thank you very much to Dr. Sacher. That was a great talk,
putting it all in context for us. I think in view of time, we
may have to pass on questions for this part of the
session.
Sorry about that, and
thank you both very much.
Thank you. So we'll move now to the next presentation.
So this is from Dr. Jonathan Rees from the University of
California Davis Comprehensive Cancer Center, and Dr.
Rees will be presenting abstract CT021,
preliminary safety and clinical activity of zoldonrasib,
RMC-9805, an oral RAS on
G12D selective tri-complex inhibitor in
patients with previously treated KRAS G12D non-small cell lung
cancer. Thank you.
Good afternoon.
On behalf of my co-authors and investigators, I'd like to thank
the conference organizers for the opportunity to present the preliminary
safety and clinical activity of zoldonrasib, formerly known as
RMC-9805, an oral RAS on
G12D selective tri-complex inhibitor in
patients with previously treated KRAS G12D
non-small cell lung cancer.
Here are my disclosures.
RAS is a GTPase that transitions between an inactive
GDP-bound off state to a
GTP-bound on state. Under normal
conditions, the system is tightly regulated, with RAS on
proteins controlling cell growth.
With RAS cancer mutations, there's excessive RAS on signaling
that drives uncontrolled cell growth.
KRAS mutations are numerous, but mainly concentrated on
G12, G13, and Q61.
KRAS G12D is the most common oncogenic RAS mutation
in human tumors and lacks an approved targeted treatment.
As shown in the figure, 61,000 new patients per year
in the United States are diagnosed with KRAS G12D cancers.
This includes 40% of pancreatic adenocarcinoma,
15% of colorectal cancer, and
4% of non-small cell lung cancer, which is about the same
frequency in non-small cell lung cancer as ALK fusion non-small cell lung
cancer.
KRAS G12D mutations in non-small cell lung cancer
are often associated with a never or light smoking status,
low tumor mutational burden, and low PDL1
expression compared to non-G12D KRAS mutant
tumors. Treatment options for patients with KRAS
G12D non-small cell lung cancer that's advanced or
metastatic after progression on platinum-based chemotherapy
and immune checkpoint inhibitors are limited.
The standard of care in this setting is docetaxel with
consideration of ramucirumab that can be toxic and has low
response rates, a median progression-free survival in the three to
four and a half month range, and limited overall survival.
This illustrates a large unmet need for targeted therapies in
KRAS G12D mutated non-small cell lung cancer.
Zoldonrasib is an oral mutant selective covalent inhibitor
targeting the on active GTP-bound state of RAS
G12D. Promising preliminary safety and
clinical activity has previously been reported in pancreatic
adenocarcinoma and non-small cell lung cancer, and
zoldonrasib has breakthrough FDA designation based on
these results in non-small cell lung cancer. Dr.
Arbor presented the early data from this study last
year, and here I present more patients and a longer duration of
follow-up.
Zoldonrasib's mechanism of action is shown here in the
cartoon. It binds inside the cell to cyclophilin A, a protein
abundant in cells, forms a binary complex, and then has
non-covalent binding with RAS on, and then in
G12D, binds to 12 aspartic acid. The
resulting tri-complex sterically occludes RAF
interaction and inhibits RAS on oncogenic activity
and downstream signaling.
Zoldonrasib drives deep and durable regressions in KRAS
G12D non-small cell lung cancer preclinical models in
vivo. Here I show deep responses in the waterfall plot in these
preclinical xenograft models, and these responses were durable,
as you can see, in the opposite Kaplan-Meier curve for
xenografts,
with prolonged progression-free survival and these durable
responsesIn part based on this exciting
preclinical data, RMC9805001
Phase 1 study was initiated. Here I present arm A
zoldanrasib monotherapy. Key eligibility criteria
include patients with advanced solid tumors with KRAS
G12D mutations. They have to have had progressed on prior
standard therapy appropriate for tumor type and stage, good
performance status, zero to one, and no active brain metastases,
although patients with stable, asymptomatic, treated brain
metastases were allowed on study.
Key endpoints include safety and tolerability and anti-tumor
activity, as well as pharmacokinetics.
The
PK data was presented in previous presentations.
For dose escalation, zoldanrasib was administered orally
once daily or twice a day in a 21-day treatment
cycle with escalating doses from 100 milligrams
daily to 1,200 milligrams daily and 300 milligrams twice a
day to 600 milligrams twice a day. The maximum
administered dose was 1,200 milligrams daily.
No dose-limiting toxicities were observed.
The maximum tolerated dose was not reached, and 1,200
milligrams oral daily was selected as the recommended Phase
2 dose in pancreatic adenocarcinoma and non-small cell lung
cancer, including the part two of this study, expansion and dose
optimization.
Today, I'm going to present the non-small cell lung cancer data for
patients treated with zoldanrasib at the 1,200 milligram
daily dose, which was established as the recommended Phase 2 dose.
Forty patients encompass the safety population, and then for the
efficacy population, we show 20 patients who've received prior
immune checkpoint inhibitor and platinum-based chemotherapy
without prior docetaxel. This enables an appropriate
comparison between that second-line patient population that's
progressed on chemo IO but has not received standard of care
docetaxel.
Median age was 66 in the safety population.
There were more women than men treated.
All patients had good performance status, the majority
PS1. In the safety population,
55% were current or former smokers, 45% never
smokers, and slightly inverse in the
efficacy population of patients treated with ICI and platinum chemo, but
no docetaxel. The number of prior anticancer treatments for the
safety population,
median of two with a range of zero to five, and patients who received ICI
and platinum without prior docetaxel, median of one with a range of
one to four. Twenty-five percent of patients in the safety population
had brain metastases at baseline and
19% in the efficacy population. The
majority of patients were metastatic at diagnosis.
Here I present the treatment-related adverse events for patients treated with
zoldanrasib at the recommended Phase 2 dose.
Overall, zoldanrasib was well-tolerated, with the majority of
treatment-related adverse events Grade 1 and GI related, such
as nausea, vomiting, and diarrhea.
In terms of rash, it occurred in 18% of patients, all
Grade 1. In terms of liver function abnormalities, AST
was increased in 10% of patients. Again, all Grade 1.
No treatment-related Grade 4 or Grade 5 AEs
or SAEs have been reported. Grade 3 treatment-related
adverse events include one patient with Grade 3 diarrhea, two
patients with Grade 3 CPK elevation, and one patient with Grade
3 facial paresis.
Here I present the dose modification and dose intensity in patients with
KRAS G12D non-small cell lung cancer treated with zoldanrasib at
this dose. Overall, 15% of patients required dose
interruption, one patient or 3% had dose reduction,
and two patients or 5% discontinued zoldanrasib.
The reasons for discontinuation included one patient with Grade 1
pneumonitis that was mandated per protocol and one patient with Grade
1 vomiting.
Zoldanrasib relative dose intensity mean was
94% and median was 97%.
The delivery of zoldanrasib dose intensity was high.
Here's the waterfall plot of shrinkage of target lesion
and also the overall response rate and disease control rate of patients treated
with zoldanrasib at this dose. As you can see, the majority of
patients had tumor shrinkage, including deep and durable
responses. The overall response rate was 52%,
and these were confirmed responses.
The disease control rate was 93%. The median time
to response was 1.4 months. The median duration of
response was not reached with the lower bound of the 95%
confidence interval at 8.3 months, and this
encompasses a median follow-up time of 13.1
months.
Here's the Kaplan-Meier curve for progression-free survival of patients
treated with zoldanrasib at the 1,200 milligram dose.
The median progression-free survival was 11.1 months,
and the 12-month PFS was 48%. Again,
this is the efficacy population presented who received ICI and
platinum-based chemo but no prior docetaxel, and again,
median follow-up was 13.1 months.
Here is the Kaplan-Meier curve of preliminary overall survival in
patients with KRAS G12D non-small cell lung cancer treated with
zoldanrasib at the 1,200 milligram dose.
The median overall survival was not reached, and at
one year, 73% of patients were
alive.This
is the ctDNA molecular response data of patients treated with
zoldanrasib at the recommended phase two dose.
Marked reduction in KRAS G12D variant allele fraction in
ctDNA as determined by the Guardant Infinity assay was
noted. Fifteen out of 27 patients treated
with zoldanrasib had ctDNA available at baseline
and at cycle two, day one. 87% or
13 out of 15 patients had more than 50%
clearance and 73% had
100% clearance.
In conclusion, zoldanrasib is an oral potent
mutant-selective covalent inhibitor of RAS on G12D.
It is well-tolerated and manageable, with primarily grade one
treatment-related adverse events.
No grade four or grade five treatment-related adverse events were noted,
and zoldanrasib was able to be delivered with a high dose
intensity. Zoldanrasib has demonstrated an encouraging
clinical activity at the recommended phase two dose of
1,200 milligrams taken orally once daily as
measured by confirmed response rate, duration of response,
progression-free survival, and preliminary overall survival in
patients with previously treated KRAS G12D non-small cell
lung cancer. Preliminary safety and anti-tumor activity
support the continuing development of zoldanrasib as a single agent
and in rational combinations with other therapies, including the
multi-selective RAS inhibitor, deruxinrasib, in solid
tumors, standard of care regimens such as platinum-based
chemotherapy and immune checkpoint inhibitors in non-small cell lung
cancer, and standard of care regimens for GI cancers.
We'd like to thank all the patients who participated in this study, their families
who supported them, and the clinical investigators and research staff who cared for
them. The RMC-9805-001 study is sponsored by Revolution
Medicines, and please scan the QR code to view this oral presentation.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Reese. I would now like to welcome Dr.
Daniel Tan from the National Cancer Center in Singapore to be
the discussant and to put these findings into context.
And whilst we're waiting for Dr. Tan to get to the podium,
just a reminder to please post questions online.
There will be time at the end of the session to
address those.
Okay.
Thank you for the introduction, and
I'd like to thank the organizers for the opportunity to discuss this exciting
abstract. And I've titled my discussion, "KRAS G12D:
Tackling the Next Frontier of Molecularly Defined Non-Small Cell Lung Cancer."
My name is Daniel Tan from the National Cancer Center in Singapore.
These are my disclosures.
So KRAS G12D is the most common KRAS allele across
cancers.
You can see variable prevalence across three of the common
cancers: colorectal cancer, non-small cell lung cancer, and
pancreatic adenocarcinoma,
with lung cancer
having a prevalence of 5%.
This is the second or third most common KRAS mutation in
non-small cell lung cancer. And you can see one of the
unique features of this particular KRAS mutation is that there is an
association with never smokers. With the Pan Asia
cohort, we saw a prevalence of up to 60% of never smokers.
It is associated with a high oncogenic potential in a range of preclinical
models, including genetically engineered mouse models as well as
isogenic cell line models looking at different KRAS allele frequencies,
and in general, has been found to be associated with unfavorable
outcomes,
and you can see here in real-world dataset showing a median
overall survival of 7.4 months in patients treated
with IO monotherapy.
KRAS G12D lacks the cysteine residue that was
exploited in some of the early chemistry efforts, exploiting that
shallow pocket where covalent inhibitors could bind in the
GDP-off state, such as sotorasib and adagrasib that was previously
covered.
There are now multiple ongoing efforts targeting KRAS
G12D with smaller molecules through structural optimization and
rational design, and we've seen
recently some emerging data in this field.
This includes protein degraders that was recently published, so
PROTACs
targeting KRAS G12D.
We've also seen non-covalent binding inhibitors that can target both
the GDP bound-off and GDP on state,
and
these tri-complex inhibitors
that really have been
pioneered by Revolution Medicine.
And today, I'll be discussing the zoldanrasib
abstract that was presented last year with showing an
objective response rate of 61% but had very limited follow-up data at that
point.
So just to give a high-level overview of the study,
you can see this was a study schema and explored 150
milligrams all the way to 1,200 milligrams per day, and that's the recommended
phase two dose.
In terms of safety, this has really quite
minimal side effects
with mild GI toxicities, mainly in grade one.
And you can see this is a patient cohort that also majority were
treated with prior IO
therapy. In general, the dose interruptions were
few and minimal dose reductions and discontinuations, again
highlighting the tolerability of this particular
drugHere are the efficacy results,
and you can see
objective response rate of 52%. And with this extended
median follow-up of 13.1 months,
the PFS is 11.1 months.
And
again, this
is
currently one of the longer
follow-up data that we have with this class
of compounds.
Notably, 56% of patients were never smokers, and 19% of
patients had brain metastasis. And I'll come back to these two points
shortly. To put this data into
context, here are a selection of current and ongoing
trials targeting KRASG12D. And this table illustrates a
range of clinical activity that has been observed across KRAS inhibitors
with different modes of action that have demonstrated proof of concept
for each approach, as well as the pipeline of other assets that
are also in development.
I think given the small sample size and wide range of efficacy, it is
important to point out potential impact of additional molecular
features that may influence outcome to KRAS inhibitors.
Here on the left panel, I think you can see the previous and current
tobacco exposure can lead to higher proportion of elevated
PD-L1 levels and high tumor mutational burden, blunting
the response to targeted therapies as observed with other
oncogene-driven non-small cell lung cancers.
And on the right,
we know that different cancers have got different co-mutations.
And in this analysis
of 12,000
colon, lung adenocarcinoma, and pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma,
you could see that
there were distinct co-mutation networks.
And these investigators identified different nodes
observed in different tumor type contexts,
again highlighting how
important context is. And even within the same tumor
type, such as lung adenocarcinoma, between KRASG12D and
KRASG12C, we do see distinct nodes.
Again, suggesting even allelic-specific
combinations on vulnerability may be warranted in the
future. So some questions
remain, and I think the first question, it would be
important in this setting to understand whether there was any difference
in response or outcomes in patients who never smokers and patients
with past and current tobacco use.
And given up to 30% of patients can develop brain metastasis,
some pre-clinical or clinical data generated in this regard would be
helpful.
And of course, the next question is what are the development plans, and
how should we approach this?
And clearly there could be an
option to run this in the second and third line setting in the post
IO platinum-based chemotherapy setting.
And this could be run against docetaxel.
But again, I think the infrequent incidence and significant
biological heterogeneity could make it somewhat
challenging. And moreover, there is also an ongoing Phase III
trials that targets all RAS variants with the pan-RAS inhibitor
deruxinrasib
in the setting, and that readout is awaited.
How about moving to the frontline setting?
And again, the complexity here does increase with the different PD-L1
tertiles,
and the potential for different strategies in this regard.
And I think the key question here is how
this tumor type actually responds to immunotherapy.
And here we have the benefit of real-world evidence that has
highlighted the poorer outcomes
with KRASG12D, relative to KRASG12C, as seen in
these charts. And part of the reason here it's the
KRASG12D tumors are less immunogenic,
with
more low PD-L1 rates,
less effective T-cell activation, and less
T-cell infiltration as seen on multiplex spatial immunoprofiling.
How about the potential for combinations with immunotherapy?
And preclinical models here
do demonstrate that with a treatment with a G12D
inhibitor,
you can get increased T-cell infiltration, increase in MHC and
PD-L1 expression,
and
blocking of CD8
with antibody here does
accelerate tumor growth, suggesting
the contribution of the immune system
in therapeutic response.
Further, in a immunogenic syngeneic mouse model,
when you combine with immune checkpoint inhibitor, we do observe
a therapeutic synergy. And again, underscoring the importance
of and the potential for combining this with
KRASG12D inhibitors with immune checkpoint inhibitors.
With regards to resistance, I think currently we don't have too
much data with zotanutib, nor with the
tri-complex inhibitors. But again, I think this was
previously covered. We do see a host of different resistance mechanisms,
including the emergence of novel KRAS mutations,
and that forms one of the bases for the combination with zotanutib
and deruxinrasib. And
even though there's no real data with regards to the head-to-head
comparison,
we have some preclinical data showing
tumor regressions in 30 preclinical mouse models,
KRASG12D across different cancer types.
And you can see that there are a small fraction of tumors that may show
some differential tumor shrinkage when you compare both agents.
But rational combination approaches will likely require deeper understanding of
these adaptive and resistance mechanisms.I want to mention
just one point on the ctDNA and the pharmacodynamics here.
And we do have a small cluster of patients that
do
have
persistent ctDNA,
and I think this is an increasingly
emerging potential endpoint in clinical trials.
And one of the key questions would be whether the ctDNA persistence
correlates with progression-free survival, and was there a way that we can
now identify patient subsets that may progress earlier?
And can we actually use this as a setting
to escalate therapy with rational combinations?
Further, ideally, we should be able to be measuring some of these adaptive
changes beyond just ctDNA to try to better understand
the mechanism.
Now, my last slide is really just to illustrate the increasing
complexity that we are beginning to see, both from a diagnostic
point of view and as well as with increasingly precise therapies.
And here you have KRAS G12C representing 5% of all non-small
cell lung cancers, and you can see if you start
classifying them to biologically distinct subsets, you do start
whittling down each slice
of even maybe 1% of
patients with each with its own preferred standard of care.
And when you add to that the impact of PDL1 expression, the impact
of smoking status, clinical features, and co-mutation
rates, then you start to appreciate that it becomes incredibly
challenging to be able to design randomized phase III trials that can take
into account all these variables.
So to take home messages, zoldanrasib at
1,200 milligrams daily is well-tolerated and has demonstrated
excellent clinical efficacy, a response rate of 52% and
PFS of 11.1 months.
KRAS G12D is distinct from KRAS G12C with
unique allo-specific demographic and biology with potential
implications on therapeutic vulnerabilities.
And I think this is where there's a need to identify
key stratification factors, hopefully leveraging off real-world data
and clinical trials informed by high dimensional biomarkers.
And finally, with the favorable safety profile,
zoldanrasib is ideal for further evaluation of combinations
specific to KRAS G12D in non-small cell lung cancer,
but also other tumor types, and we eagerly await some of the
data around combinations and sequencing with immune checkpoint inhibitors.
With that, thank you very much.
Excellent. Thank you so much, both to Dr. Reese and Dr.
Tan. So we have time for a couple of questions.
While we're waiting for people to come up to the podium,
I think we have someone here.
Hello.
Can you hear me okay?
Yes.
Said Septi from the Massey Cancer Center.
One of the biggest problems with any of the KRAS inhibitors
is the reactivation of ERK.
And so whether you're talking about G12D or
G12C inhibitors, it seems like the tumor really
always tries to survive by upregulating through many
mechanisms ERK. Could be by amplification of KRAS,
different mutations, could be wild type NRAS or
HRAS. It always ends up being that this cell
wants to survive through this, what's been labeled the
kinase from hell, which is ERK.
So
clearly there's a very nice PFS,
but there's still intrinsic resistance.
50% of the patients, though they have G12D, they don't respond.
And then the others, eventually, within 12 months, relapse.
So have you guys looked at ERK?
Because it seems like everything converges over, not everything,
but
great majority. Have you looked at that in patients as they progressed?
I would just say i, in terms of this specific trial,
the zoldanrasib,
many patients are
still on treatment, and we're still learning about these resistance mechanisms.
So we don't have that data yet in terms of, like you saw what Dr.
Awad published in terms of the spectrum of resistance mutations and how
much
ERK... One would anticipate that ERK could be a critical node to
target.
There are rational combinations, for example, the multi-selective RAS inhibitor,
deraxasib, and so forth. In other trials, there
have been, for example, sotorasib, they did a combination study
with a MEK inhibitor, for example, and showed some modest
results. I think clinically, there's also the toxicity between some of
these MEK ERK inhibitors as well in combination.
The good thing about zoldanrasib is it's
well-tolerated, so it makes itself amenable to combinations.
I don't know if you have any other thoughts.
No. I think
ERK has been looked at from a small molecule point of view, and it
was pretty tough target,
and I think partly because of
how reactive ERK itself is when you try to inhibit it.
So
far we've had to-- I think we look forward to other
methods of inhibiting ERK other than through small molecules, perhaps.
We have time for one more question.
Hi.
Lovely presentations and great data.
We've seen with the newer generations of G12C
inhibitors that I think the role for chemotherapy, particularly in
the PDL1 less than 50% group is,
I think, questionable and doublet treatment with immunotherapy and
G12C inhibitors may offer similar efficacy.
Now we've just seen excellent data with zoldanrasib and also
the questionable benefitimmunotherapy in the G12D
subgroups. So overall, I was just wondering your views
on using triplets in first-line studies going
forward, or should we be dropping one modality of treatment?
That's a great question. I do want to emphasize, although there's published data
that there may be a subset of KRAS G12D non-small cell lung cancer
that may not benefit as much from immunotherapy, patients with G12D
non-small cell lung cancer can still derive great benefit from
immunotherapy. And so I
think that combination strategies, for example, that include
chemo immunotherapy, I think you still need to have the
immunotherapy in that context because when patients benefit, they could benefit for
some time, including G12D. And again,
KRAS G12Z is about the same frequency as alk lung cancer,
but it's more responsive to IO, although there's a subset that may be
less than your G12C, for example, because some of these are never
light smokers as an example. But I do believe it still needs to have
IO combinations, and zoldanresib is a good drug to
combine with that.
And if we have some sort of objective assessment of smoking signatures
in the tumors?
So I think we don't do this in the trial, but there have been some data
published to suggest that there's the aging clock-like signature seen more in the
KRAS G12D rather than in the smoking signatures that we observe in the
KRAS 212D. So I think to address your question, I think
at the moment we have to go deeper into the biology of KRAS G12D
tumors, but it's also a function of how deep can we go
and what kind of trial concept will that lead to.
It becomes unfeasible to do randomized studies in that
setting after that.
Thank you.
Yeah, you slice and dice something that's 4% to 5% by certain
demographics and other characteristics, it becomes hard to do larger
trials to find the answer.
Thank you.
So thank you so much. I know it's a topic we could continue to discuss, but in view
of time, we'll continue. Thank Dr. Tan and Dr.
Satcher for two excellent presentations.
So next we'll invite Dr.
Yap, Dr. Timothy Yap from MD Anderson, and he's going to
speak to us on the topic of first data disclosure of the Phase I
trial of a first-in-class combination of a WEE1 inhibitor,
zetaracib, with a PKMYT1 inhibitor
lonresorib in patients with advanced solid tumors
harboring CCNE1,
FBXW7 or PPP2R1A genomic
alterations. Thanks, Dr. Yap.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, everyone, and thank you all for being here.
On behalf of my co-investigators, I'd like to thank the
AACR Organizing Committee for giving us this opportunity
to share with you today the first data disclosure
of the Phase I trial of the first-in-class
combination of the WEE1 inhibitor zetaracib
with the PKMζ1 inhibitor lonresorib in
patients with advanced solid tumors harboring CCNE1,
FBXW7 or PPP2R1A
genomic alterations.
These are my disclosures.
Cancers with CCNE1, FBXW7, and
PPP2R1A alterations represent
areas of unmet clinical need, including ovarian
cancer, uterine cancers, bladder cancers, and
other tumors. CCNE1 amplification
induces high replication stress through premature
cell cycle S phase entry, whilst FBXW7 is
an E3 ubiquitin ligase and proteolytically
degrades cyclin E1, and therefore inactivating
FBXW7 mutations increase cyclin E1
levels and replication stress.
PPP2R1A hotspot inactivation mutations
increase replication stress. And importantly, cancers with
these alterations represent key areas of unmet clinical
need with no specific standard of care options.
Both WEE1 and PKMζ1 maintain the cell cycle
G2-M checkpoint integrity in cells with high
replication stress.
WEE1 regulates cell cycle S-phase replication,
origin firing, and G2-M checkpoint
phosphorylation of CDK1 at tyrosine 15.
In contrast, PKMζ1 regulates the G2-M cell cycle checkpoint
progression through threonine 14 phosphorylation
of CDK1, causing cell cycle arrest.
And importantly, cells under high replication stress are more
dependent on G2-M transition for DNA damage
repair.
Both zetaracib and lonresorib are in Phase I
clinical trials and have demonstrated manageable
safety profiles at their monotherapy recommended Phase
II doses.
Zetaracib is a potent, selective, and brain-penetrant
WEE1 kinase inhibitor,
whilst lonresorib is a potent selective
PKMζ1 kinase inhibitor. For
zetaracib, the most
common treatment-related adverse events included Grade 1 to
2 nausea and vomiting, creatinine increases, fatigue,
QT prolongation, and transaminase increases.
For lonresorib, the most frequent treatment-related adverse events
included Grade 1 or 2 rash, nausea and vomiting,
anemia, and
fatigue.PKMζ1
inhibitor and WEE1 inhibitors in combination are synergistic
in CCNE1 amplification cells in vitro.
In fact,
WEE1 was actually identified as a top synthetic lethal hit
in PKMζ1 chemogenomic screens, and the
combination of the WEE1 inhibitors zetarastib and
lanresortib, the PKMζ1 inhibitor, is highly synergistic
at sublethal doses.
The whole mechanistic rationale here is that WEE1 inhibition
exacerbates CCNE1 amplification-induced replication
stress during the cell cycle S phase.
And at the G2M checkpoint, WEE1 and PKMζ1
inhibition reduce CDK1 phosphorylation,
causing its hyperactivation, and therefore, cells carrying
unrepaired DNA damage are prematurely
driven into mitosis, leading to mitotic
catastrophe and eventual cell death.
Zetarastib and lanresortib in combination have demonstrated strong
synthetic lethality in vivo. There have been compelling
synergy of both drugs, leading to durable regressions
in multiple tumor types, as shown here, with CCNE1
amplification, cyclin E1 overexpression, and
also FBXW7 mutation cancers across different tumor
types. Tumor regressions as well importantly were observed with both
continuous dosing and intermittent dosing schedules at
sub-MTD doses.
The combination was also very well-tolerated.
And these in vitro and in vivo data provided the
supporting evidence to proceed to a phase I
dose-escalation trial, as shown on the left-hand side in
the red box. We use a Boin design to
explore different doses of both drugs with
zetarastib given continuously and lanresortib given on an
intermittent three days on, four days
off schedule.
The key inclusion criteria included that all patients were required to be
advanced, resistant, or refractory solid tumor patients with
CCNE1 amplification and/or FBXW7
mutations and/or PBP201A
mutations. Key inclusion criteria included any prior
PKMζ1 or WEE1 inhibitors and a
QTCf of greater than 450 milligrams
milliseconds.
Primary objectives included the safety and tolerability of the combination,
the maximum tolerated dose for the combination.
While secondary objectives included the preliminary
antitumor activity, the PK, and the
pharmacodynamics of the combination.
Here are the baseline characteristics of the patients treated.
You'll see that we treated a total of 62 patients, median
age of 61 years. There were more females than males
treated because of the tumor types treated in trial.
All patients had an ECOG performance status of
zero to one. This was a heavily pretreated patient
population with a median of three prior lines of
systemic anticancer therapies and up to nine.
Seventy-three percent of patients had at least three prior lines
of anticancer therapies. Eighty-nine percent of patients had
prior platinum. In terms of the tumor types, the most common cancer
types included ovarian, colorectal,
pancreas, breast, and esophageal cancer.
Ninety-two percent of patients with ovarian cancer had
platinum-resistant or refractory disease.
The most common alterations included CCNE1
amplification in 56% of patients,
FBXW7 mutations in 39% of patients.
Here is the safety profile of the combination.
You'll see that the safety profile was manageable and in line
with either drug given as monotherapy.
The most commonly reported treatment-related adverse events included
nausea, vomiting, asthenia, anemia,
rash, and erythema, but these were mainly grade one to
two. Grade three or greater toxicities were rare
and uncommon. No patients discontinued drug treatments
due to treatment-related adverse events importantly.
Here are the pharmacokinetic data.
Lanresortib exposures in combination with zetarastib were
in line with monotherapy PK.
In particular, in combination, lanresortib PK exposures were approximately
dose proportional with a half-life of six to nine
hours.
Here are the PK data for zetarastib, and you can see that the
exposures in combination with lanresortib were in
line with monotherapy PK.
And again, in combination, zetarastib showed an exposure that
increased linearly with the dose and had a half-life of
three to four days.
Importantly, to date, there have been no signs of drug-drug interactions
leading to exposure differences in zetarastib exposed.
Here are the pharmacodynamic data.
We observed robust target engagement of
zetarastib and lanresortib achieved across
multiple different dose levels. You'll see here on the left-hand side
phospho-CDK1 reductions observed in paired tumor
biopsies. We also saw reductions in
both phosphorylation of CDK1 at both
threonine 14 and tyrosine 15, indicating
target engagement of both inhibitors.We also
observed, as you can see on the right-hand side, increases in gamma H2AX
indicating DNA damage induction observed in the
majority of patients.
Here the anti-tumor activity, we observed frequent and
deep tumor shrinkage with a combination in heavily
pre-treated patients across multiple different tumor types
in all patients and in all dose levels shown here in this
waterfall plot.
Overall, 51% of these 51 patients with target
lesions showed tumor shrinkage, 10 patients achieved
radiological responses, seven patients with
CCNE1 amplification ovarian cancer,
one patient with FBXW7 mutation ovarian cancer, a
patient with CCNE1 amplified and FBXW7 mutation
HR positive, HER2 positive breast cancer,
and a patient with an FBXW7 mutation colorectal
cancer.
The swimmer plot shows the clinical benefit observed over time.
You'll see that 31% of patients had a treatment duration of
greater than 16 weeks, 15% had a treatment duration of greater
than 32 weeks. The disease control rate was
68.5%.
When we now look at the ovarian cancer population, we saw
robust anti-tumor activity observed in
resistant refractory ovarian cancer patients.
As you can see in the waterfall plot shown here, out of 24 evaluable
patients, the overall response was 37.5%,
and when we look at the potential RP2D, which was MTD two,
the overall response was 50%.
Eighty percent of these patients with ovarian cancer experienced tumor shrinkage.
There were durable responses observed in at least 10 patients or
37% of these patients have been on treatment now for greater than
16 weeks. And six patients are still ongoing
on treatment. Three additional resist PRs have actually
been observed since the data cut-off of 25th of
March.
Now when we look more specifically at the CCNE1
amplified ovarian cancer patients, again, we saw that the
anti-tumor activity was further enriched in these resistant
refractory patients. And out of 19 evaluable
patients, the overall response was 42%.
And again, the potential RP2D or MTD two,
the overall response was 60%, with 81% of
these patients experiencing some tumor shrinkage and durable
responses were observed in at least 41% of these patients or nine
patients who have been on treatment for greater than 16 weeks.
Six patients are still ongoing, and again, three additional PRs have been
observed since the data cut-off.
I'd like to share
one of our patients and in terms of their response in a case study here, a
radiological partial response that we observed.
This is a patient with advanced breast cancer
who had an FBXW7 mutation and
CCNE1 amplification. This is a patient with
HR positive, HER2 positive breast cancer.
She was heavily pre-treated with nine prior lines of
chemotherapy agents and also anti-HER2 therapies,
including multiple different ADCs such as trastuzumab
and also trastuzumab emtansine and also trastuzumab
deruxtecan.
This patient remained on study for 29 weeks, and you can see a nice
response radiologically amounting to a partial
response in the disease.
These anti-tumor activity data are supported by the molecular
responses that we observed in ctDNA analysis across
different tumor types. We observed a ctDNA molecular response
rate of 47% in all patients
across all dose levels.
The molecular response rate when observed in ovarian cancer was
up at 67%, as seen on the right-hand side.
So in terms of our next steps,
we're now undertaking dose and schedule optimization of this
combination. And based on strong in vivo synergy and
durable regressions observed on both the
continuous and the intermittent schedules of zetaracib,
we're now looking at intermittent scheduling and based on population
PK modeling of zetaracib exposures, this does suggest that
intermittent schedules may actually reduce the low-grade toxicities that we
have observed whilst maintaining the
efficacy.
These are the take home messages.
We've produced and presented today the first early
clinical proof of concept for the synthetic lethal
combination of the WEE1 inhibitor zetaracib
plus the PKMiet one inhibitor lanresorazib in multiple
different tumor types with CCNE1 amplification,
FBXW7 mutations, or PPP2R1A
mutation tumors.
The combination is well-tolerated and demonstrates its strong anti-tumor
activity, particularly in patients with resistant
and refractory ovarian cancer. The most common treatment-related
adverse events were mainly grade one to two and included
nausea and vomiting, asthenia, anemia, rash, and
erythema.
Importantly, there were no clinically relevant myelosuppression events that were
observed as a safety concern.
And in patients with ovarian cancer, 80% showed tumor
shrinkage, and the overall response was 37%, and
the disease control rate was up at
87.5%.And the response rate was further
enriched in CCNE1-amplified patients at the potential
RP2d. The molecular response rate of
forty-seven percent was observed in the total population and
was sixty-seven percent in patients with ovarian cancer.
Importantly, we've also observed responses in patients following progression
on or after ADC treatment, including
movituximab, T-DXd, and TDM1.
Currently, schedule and dose optimization in multiple different tumor types
is ongoing,
and therefore, this oral combination may provide a novel therapeutic
option for patients harboring CCNE1 amplification,
FBXW7 mutations, and PPP2R1A
mutations across multiple tumor types with
high unmet medical need.
And based on these data, we're pleased to say that and to announce that this
combination has now been granted FDA Fast Track
designation in patients with ovarian cancer harboring
CCNE1 amplification, FBXW7 mutations,
and PPP2R1A deleterious mutations.
To end, I'd like to thank all of our patients and their caregivers,
all of the co-investigators and study site staff involved in
the study,
our WO Pharm study team, the Repair Therapeutics team,
and also the CROs. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Dr. Yap.
Now we'll invite Dr. Kathleen Moore from the University of Nebraska to
place in context these data and in the context of the
bigger picture of synthetic lethal and replication stress targeting
strategies.
Good afternoon, esteemed colleagues.
It is my really great privilege to have been asked to distill this exciting
phase one work.
These are my disclosures. I just want to start with the kind of so what, and I'm
actually using a figure that was made by Dr.
Yap for a symposium earlier this year.
When we're developing new regimens that target DNA damage response, what are
we really trying to do? Well, I think this is true for all of drug
development. We're trying to figure out the right drug in
the right tumor, what's the biomarker at the right dose, in the right
sequence of their therapy, and for the right duration.
This is the Goldilocks principle. We want to get it just right.
And in DNA damage response therapies, we've struggled with this, to be perfectly
honest. You can see in the little pink olive, this is PARP inhibitors, where we got
closest to the Goldilocks principle.
Hopefully, with PARP-1 selectives, maybe we'll get a little bit more in
range. But we have not accomplished this with WEE1 kinase
inhibitors. Far from it. We have been well outside the
risk-benefit ratio, but are we on the cusp of finally moving
this promising therapy into clinical action? I think remains to be seen.
We've been working on it for nineteen years.
This is not a new target. And with a lot of promising
efficacy signals, we've just never, until recently,
gotten the risk-benefit ratio right to move this into larger phase clinical trials.
And again, are we on the cusp of finally accomplishing this?
It appears so. So there's four aspects of Dr.
Yap's presentation that I want to focus on.
I'm going to start with the rationale, specifically around ovarian cancer.
And he mentioned this briefly at the beginning of his talk.
Why look at ovarian cancer? Well, Cyclin E
amplification we'll find at diagnosis in about twenty percent
of our patients, and at diagnosis, it's mutually exclusive with BRCA.
So it's not a huge number, but not small.
We will find far more patients' tumors harbor
Cyclin E overexpression, and the ranges vary based on
the data sets used and the cut point, but over fifty
percent. And we have increasing data that both of these, to different
degrees, are important prognostically, which will be very important as
we move these into late-phase clinical trials and understanding the
benchmarks of the control arms. But let's just focus a little bit
on Cyclin E overexpression, because if we're going to develop this, can we develop
it for a more broad population? What's really going on here?
Why are these tumors Cyclin E overexpressed?
Well, certainly some of them have amplification, and most tumors with
amplification, not all, have overexpression.
But most tumors with overexpression are not amplified. What's driving this?
Well, it can be transcriptionally driven.
It can be driven by dysregulation of non-coding regulatory
mRNA. It can be upregulated because you've
suppressed degradation pathways.
And of interest in ovarian cancer, and this needs to be validated, we
find maybe a high prevalence of these low molecular
weight Cyclin E isoforms
in ovarian cancer. These isoforms have lost their
N-terminus, so they're stuck in the cytoplasm.
They have so much higher affinity
for CDK2, and they are dependent on
CDK1 for their control. And so remember,
MIT1 also lives in the cytoplasm. It inhibits
CDK1 and mitotic entry, and so it's a critical
pathway for controlling these isoforms, so keep that in mind when we think about
the rationale of this combination, particularly in ovarian cancer.
So there is quite a bit of rationale here.
Let's put the efficacy of MYTHIC in context, and what I'm showing you here
are monotherapy WEE1 kinase inhibitor clinical trials
across the years in order. If we
look-studies that just enrolled all comers, sort of
platinum-resistant ovarian cancer not otherwise specified.
The efficacy signal's really pretty meh.
If you start to look at any kind of selection for cyclin E, whether
it's amplification, overexpression, both, either,
you find higher, actually quite promising signals
of efficacy without a huge gradient.
Again, my question being, do we have to have amplification, or is
overexpression appropriate here?
But when you look at the-- And these are small numbers.
When you look at the durations of responses, median progression-free survival,
this isn't great. And so it raises the specter of
adaptive tumor
changes and mechanisms of resistance and what's driving this.
And the truth is, we don't yet know.
But MYT1 is a possible culprit here.
If we have MYT1 overexpression, it can rescue
WEE1-inhibited cells through its behavior in
CDK1. And remember I told you about its
activity with these low molecular weight isoforms.
So there is some rationale here that this combination's not only potentially
synthetically lethal but also may be overcoming
some hypothetical mechanism of resistance.
So does the efficacy in mythic give us hope that this is true?
Maybe. A 60% response rate in the 10
patients, small numbers, who were cyclin E amplified
and treated at what they think is maybe likely the recommended phase two dose
looks promising. Now what I want to see is that duration.
I want to see
signals of time to event being prolonged to really get
excited. But this is a nice first signal of efficacy.
So we've talked about rationale and efficacy.
I alluded to the fact that 19 years of work has gone by,
kind of thwarted by that risk-benefit ratio.
So what does safety look like? Well, Dr. Yap showed you this.
I'm going to highlight the dose that seems to be the favored right
now, and it looks pretty good. Low rates of high-grade
toxicities. Let's put this in context with our history.
And again, apples and oranges and pears.
I'm comparing first, second, and third generation WEE1 kinase
inhibitors. Of course, these better look better,
right? And they do. We see far less hematologic
toxicity with later generation WEE1 kinase inhibitors.
And I bring this up because for those of you that may not be
maybe as old as me, some of us have a lot of PTSD
around the neutropenic deaths that were seen early on in the development.
And so there is some caution that is warranted in moving this class of agents into
the wild, as we say, into later-phase clinical trials.
Also important, though, are the other signals of improved tolerability, and I'm
going to come back to that word in a moment, that we see.
I don't even see diarrhea on the list of things that he showed, and this was a big
problem in the earlier generations of WEE1 kinase
inhibitors. Fatigue looks half as common.
Small numbers. Apples and oranges.
We need to follow this up, but the early signals here are
promising. But this is just safety.
Does that really mean tolerability?
And we use this term
probably inappropriately. Tolerability means we make a medication or a regimen that
patients can tolerate when they are taking it at home, and they stay on
it without feeling terrible. How do we judge that on clinical trials?
We don't do a great job of this, speaking as a phase one trialist
myself, and we need to get better. I'm showing you one tool.
This is PRO CTCAEs. You pick what symptoms you're
interested in, and you ask the patient to self-report the frequency,
severity, how much it impairs their activities of daily living.
This was done in a WEE1 trial led by Stephanie LaRowe et al.
and published, and I think a lot of people missed it.
But it showed us that patients tell us what the
toxicities are, and they may not be the things that rise to our attention
in terms of high-grade toxicity. But low-grade, repetitive
toxicities drove dose modifications.
This is the type of data we need to understand in dose optimization and,
quite frankly, needs to be given equal weight to
efficacy and safety when we're picking which regimen should move into
late-phase clinical trials.
Dr. Yap took you through the dose finding for the study, and it's
really a master class. You'll notice the
recommended phase two dose is for the monotherapy at the top.
But they're looking at a variety of doses, not pushing
things just to the maximum dose patients can tolerate.
MTD means the maximum dose before we hurt people.
That doesn't mean it's tolerated.
They're looking at PD to try and figure out if there's a biological
equivalent dose. They're setting a baseline threshold for where
they want to see WEE1 inhibition levels above
which we don't maybe need to be that high.
So we can continue to look at intermittent dosing. You heard Dr.
Yap reference this. How much of each of these drugs do I need to get
synthetic lethality, to overcome resistance, whatever the mechanism is,
and not hurt people with toxicity?
Drug regimens that patients can tolerate and stay on actually help
them. Drug regimens that are so hard to stay on that patients don't take, don't
work. And so this is really a master class in how that's done.
And so if we get this rationale,
efficacy,
tolerability, safety, where does it fit in
the increasing complex world of ovarian cancer?
Well, this is a timeline of developments in platinum-resistant ovarian cancer, and
it's an exciting time. In the last two years, we've had four approvals,
three based on PFS and OS, which is transformative
in and of itself because we've never shown overall survival advantage in
ovarian cancer. But the magnitude of those benefits was
modest. And so there's room still to be transformational.
Right now, there's a festival of phase three studies ongoing
in platinum-resistant ovarian cancer with antibody drug conjugates,
but also cell cycle inhibitors are already here.
There's a CDK2 in a phase three study and a zenocertinib
WEE1. So knowing that, where does mythic fit in a
sequencing standpoint, and can we use our science to really figure that out
and bring this in in a logical, science-driven way rather than just the
cookie-cutter studies that we do?
OrDo we relegate it to platinum-resistant ovarian cancer?
Can it move up? We're starting to see data looking at
frontline ovarian cancer and the overlap in biomarkers.
This study showing us that even though cyclin E
amplification and BRCA are mutually exclusive, overexpression is not.
About 13% of BRCA will have overexpression.
About 40% of HRD positive tumors will have overexpression.
What does that mean prognostically?
What does that mean in terms of their response to PARP inhibitors?
We're starting to get this out. You can see, I know it's small, but in the green
circles, you can see the hazard ratios of
prognosis, that we're getting a growing sense of
where are our true high unmet needs apart from just HRD
yes/no. Hopefully, that's going to go away.
And if this is a tolerable effective regimen, can it move into frontline?
That remains to be seen. So in conclusion, I'd like to congratulate Dr.
Yap and the study team. I look forward to see what comes
next. My questions really center on the biomarker selection.
Obviously, that's what I talked about a lot.
Does it have to be amplified, or can we do overexpression?
And do we need to further figure out this low molecular weight isoform
component to see if it matters? These two drugs are two
drugs may be given intermittently. That can be complex.
There's two drugs coming that are combined MYT1/WE1.
You can look at SGR-3515 in the poster session
tomorrow, so I didn't want to steal their thunder by putting things in today.
But which one's better? We don't know yet, so it's a question without an
answer. But how do we really bring this to our patients in the best way, and where
does it fit? What is the just right for this combination in
ovarian cancer remains to be seen. Thank you.
So we'll thank Dr. Moore for a wonderful discussion and
Dr. Yap for the presentation, and we'll move to the last part
of this session.
Thank you again. I would now like to welcome
to the stage Dr. Afshin Delati,
who comes from the University Hospital Seidman Cancer Center and Case
Western University in Cleveland, Ohio, who will be
presenting early clinical activity from the Phase 1 evaluation
of CID-078, a novel cyclin
A/B RxR inhibitor in patients with advanced solid
tumors. Thank you. Dr. Delati.
Okay.
Good afternoon. On behalf of my co-investigators, I would
like to thank the organizers for the opportunity
to present the initial data of an ongoing
Phase 1 trial of CID-078, a
novel cyclin A/B RxR inhibitor
in patients with advanced solid tumors.
Here are my conflicts of interest.
This schematic depicts the cell cycle in which the
cyclin-dependent kinase retinoblastoma
E2F axis plays a critical role in cell cycle
progression, and Rb acts as a break that
silences E2F-targeted genes required for
progression through S, G2, and M phase.
E2F signaling pathway plays a crucial role in cell cycle
regulation and cancer cell growth.
Any alteration in cyclin-dependent kinases,
cyclins, or Rb can enhance E2F
activity, leading to cellular proliferation.
Indeed, loss of Rb function is seen in
7% of all malignancies, especially in small cell
lung cancer, leiomyosarcoma, triple-negative breast
cancer, and other high-grade neuroendocrine cancers and
osteosarcomas. Of note, a similar
phenotype may occur in cases of
CDK2A deficiency.
CID-078 is a novel
first-in-class oral macrocyclic agent
that binds to what was previously thought to be an undruggable
target, interacting with a hydrophobic patch on
cyclin A and cyclin B complexes in the
RxR motif.
At this AACR 2026 meeting, other sessions
featuring CID-078 have been
discussed about the chemistry yesterday, and the
biology will be discussed tomorrow at another session.
CID-078 blocks the interaction of cyclin
A with E2F, and on cyclin B,
CID-078 blocks its interaction with
MYT1. This combined interaction leads to the
accumulation of DNA damage and activation
of the spindle assembly checkpoint, SAC,
ultimately resulting in mitotic catastrophe and
apoptosis.
In vitro, CID-078 has significant
antiproliferative effects with IC50s in the
nanomolar range for a variety of malignancies, with
significantly lower IC50s in tumors with
altered Rb pathway and high E2F activity.
As an example, small cell lung cancer cell lines show
robust sensitivity to
CID-078.
In normal cells, modulation of the cyclin A
E2F1 interaction leads to further
increase in E2F signaling and S-phase progression with
no cellular toxicityHowever, in cancer
cells, blockade of this cyclin A E2F interaction
enhances the E2F activity to what we call a
tipping point, where the overstimulated E2F
activity leads to cellular apoptosis and death.
This differential between normal and cancer cells
predicts for a potential high therapeutic index and
low normal cell toxicity.
Herein, we report the dose escalation part of this
first-in-human study in patients with solid tumors.
12 different dose levels have been enrolled, and dose
escalation is continuing.
In addition, backfill slots focusing on small cell lung cancer,
triple-negative breast cancer, or tumors with
RB1 or CDKN2A loss have been enrolled.
CID-078 is given orally twice daily
till disease progression or toxicity.
Standard phase one objectives are employed, including
toxicity and adverse events and dose
selection for expansion cohorts.
Pharmacokinetics, anti-tumor activity, and
pharmacodynamic marker assessment are secondary
objectives.
A total of 79 patients at data cutoff have been
enrolled. Demographics including sex,
race, ethnicity, and tumor characteristics are
depicted on this slide.
Nearly one-quarter of the patients have sarcoma and
10% small cell lung cancer. This is a very
heavily pretreated population. Indeed,
64% of patients have had more than three lines of prior
therapy, 57% of the patients
enrolled have had RB1 alterations.
Now let's look at the safety profile.
CID-078 has been well-tolerated.
Minimal grade three alterations have been seen.
The most common treatment-related adverse event has been nausea
in about 20% of patients, followed by fatigue
in 12%. Other low-level
gastrointestinal treatment-related adverse events, including
diarrhea and diminished appetite, have been
reported.
Looking now at adverse events by dose level, no clear
signal of dose relatedness has been seen.
For example, the rate of treatment-related adverse event
has not increased by dose level at this point, and no
apparent dose adverse event relationship has been observed.
Two transitory grade three ALT increases have been seen at
lower doses of 360 milligrams BID,
respectively,
both resolved by holding the dose of the drug.
Neither of these patients had concurrent elevations in other liver
function tests, including bilirubin.
The pharmacokinetic profile of CID-078 has been
linear across dose ranges from
40 to 960 milligrams.
Clinical exposure has been consistent with preclinical
observations with an excellent predicted oral
bioavailability of 20%.
Terminal half-life is approximately three hours,
and no dose accumulation of the drug has been seen with repetitive
dosing.
No exposure saturation has been seen to date.
As investigators in this phase one study, we are excited to
see proof of principle clinical activity during the
escalation phase of the trial, especially in
diseases where such a response was predicted.
I will provide two such examples on the following slides.
In this example, a 28-year-old patient with
Li-Fraumeni syndrome with a history of multiple prior
malignancies dating back to 2012
and multiple rounds of prior cytotoxic
chemotherapy with different regimens and radiation therapy was
treated with CID-078 at a dose of
480 milligrams BID for
recurrent osteosarcoma, the patient's latest
malignancy. This osteosarcoma carried an RB1
loss-of-function frame shift alteration in addition to
the germline TP53 alteration.
A RECIST-defined confirmed response as well as metabolic
response was seen as visible on this PET
scan.
This is a case of a 74-year-old female
with metastatic well-differentiated neuroendocrine
tumor originating from the duodenum and metastatic to the
liver and lungs who had three lines of prior therapy.
Although well-differentiated neuroendocrine tumors
generally lack our retinoblastoma alterations and are
considered retinoblastoma proficient,
this patient had a documented RB dysfunction as
documented by RB protein loss as assessed
by immunohistochemistry.
The patient was dosed at 360 milligrams BID with
a confirmed response as can be seen on the following CT
scan. The patient has received 10 cycles of
therapy to date.
In conclusion, CID-078 is a novel
first-in-class oral macrocycle with a
unique and intricate mechanism of action targeting
a previously undruggable target.PK
analysis shows linear disposition.
CID078 is very safe, and the adverse
events have been very mild with an excellent safety profile to
date.
The initial responses seen are within the target
population of Rb-altered tumors.
I'd like to thank all the patients who enrolled on the study, the family
members, our dedicated research staff, and all my
co-investigators who participated in this clinical trial.
This study has been sponsored by Circle Pharma.
Thank you for your attention.
Thank you, Dr Delati. I would now like to welcome Dr.
Allyson Schram from the Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center, who will
be our discussant and put these findings into context.
Hello, everyone. Thank you for having me.
Today, I'll be discussing the science behind the excellent presentation by Dr.
Delati and colleagues. Yesterday and today, we heard about the
incredible chemistry and the development of
CID078. So today, I'll be taking a bit more of a
background approach. My talk is titled "Cyclin AB Inhibition: The
Next Mile in Cell
Cycle Therapy." These are my disclosures.
So cells enter G1 when activated for cell division by
stimuli, growth factors, hormones, and environmental changes.
Cyclin D rises, binds to and activates CDK4 and
CDK6. Cyclin E binds CDK2.
These complexes phosphorylate Rb, releasing it from
E2F and allowing E2F to transcribe genes needed for
S-phase.
The Cyclin A CDK2 complex initiates and regulates DNA
replication during S-phase.
This complex directly binds to E2F, phosphorylating it to
inhibit its DNA-binding activity.
This mechanism acts as a feedback loop that terminates the E2F-driven
S-phase transcriptional program and limits DNA replication to once per
cycle.
At the G2M checkpoint, the CDK Cyclin B complex
exists in an inactivated state due to phosphorylation by
PKMIT1 and WEE1.
CDC25B and 25C activate
the CDK1 Cyclin B complex through dephosphorylation, leading to
mitosis.
In normal cells, there's a coordinated and effective DNA
damage response. DNA damage causes DNA breaks, which
are sensed by ATM and ATR, which activate CHK1,
CHK2, and p53.
p53 transcribes p21, which inhibits the formation of the
Cyclin E CDK2 complex.
Rb is therefore not phosphorylated, preventing E2F-mediated
transcription.
Similarly, p21 inhibits the Cyclin B CDK1
complex,
and therefore, the cell cycle halts, allowing DNA repair or
apoptosis.
In cancer, the cell cycle is frequently dysregulated.
Mutations or altered expression of proteins that regulate the cell cycle are
common, and you can see these little red lightning bolts showing just some of
the more commonly mutated or altered cell cycle proteins in cancer.
These alterations allow for division of abnormal cells, promotes
genomic diversity among cancer cells, leading to the emergence of aggressive
and/or resistant clones, but can also provide a therapeutic
vulnerability as seen during today's sessions.
Replication stress and loss of coordinated checkpoints leads
to exaggerated dependencies on specific proteins.
There is increasing exploration of drugs targeting these proteins, working
by synthetic lethality. The molecular
alteration that creates the specific synthetic lethal relationship varies
based on the target. So for example, CCNE1
amplification is a common biomarker for PKMIT1,
WEE1, CHK1 and CHK2, and CDK2 inhibitors,
whereas ATM and BRCA mutations are common biomarkers for ATR
inhibitors.
This figure is busy, but you see highlighted are the proteins that are
the targets for a variety of therapeutic agents, and in black
are just some of the therapeutic agents targeting cell cycle proteins.
As you can see, it's becoming a very exciting and emerging field.
So this slide is also busy, but beyond CDK4/6
inhibitors, which are well-established in breast cancer, this shows
some early readouts from clinical trials targeting cell cycle proteins.
Each respective study on the right has a waterfall plot, and
on the top, you see the phase I data from
the PINNACLE trial of ritetapib, a p53 R220C
reactivator in patients with p53 R220C mutated solid
tumors.
The R220C mutation creates a unique pocket in p53
that's amenable to small molecules that can bind and thermally stabilize the
mutated protein in the wild type conformation.
And this mutated protein can then bind DNA and carry out the
wild type transcriptional program.
Impressively, the ritetapib monotherapy study
did show that there was monotherapy activity, as you can see.
On the second bullet point here is a waterfall plot
for a selective CDK2 inhibitor in patients with advanced solid tumors that are
enriched for CC1 amplification. In
the one down is the WEE1 inhibitor adavosertib, which we heard about briefly
before in recurrent uterine serous cancers.
And importantly, uterine serous carcinoma is a rare and very
aggressive tumor type for which standard therapies are not very
effective.And lastly, you see the waterfall plot that we just
observed from Dr. Yap's talk of the mythic trial showing a combination of a
Wone and a PKMIT1 inhibitor. So together, this really shows
that early studies are demonstrating proof of concept for targeting cell
cycle proteins.
But what about cyclin A and cyclin B?
So as a way of a bit more background, alterations in RB1 and
other key components of this pathway occur in many cancers, leading to
increased oncogenic E2F activity.
Although E2F activation is essential for cell cycle progression,
hyperactivation promotes apoptosis.
E2F downregulation at the end of S phase relies on the
interaction of cyclin A and the E2FRXL motif,
and disruption of this interaction leads to hyperactivation of
E2F and synthetic lethality in E2F-driven tumors.
CID078 is a novel oral inhibitor that binds the
RXL binding site on cyclins A and B, blocking the interaction of
E2F with the cyclin A CDK2 complex and
MIT1 with the cyclin B CDK1 complex, promoting unchecked
progression through G1S and G2M checkpoints, respectively.
This leads to propagation of DNA damage and mitotic catastrophe in
E2F high tumors.
On the bottom right, you see a waterfall plot from xenograft models and select
sensitive tumor types, and this really shows proof of concept,
but also that E2F transcription correlates with efficacy.
So just now we heard Dr. Delatte's presentation discussing the
initial results from a phase one study of CID078.
The trial schema is shown here, and they utilized a Bowen design.
Many different dose levels were explored, as you can see, with a wide range from
forty milligrams twice daily up to twelve sixty twice daily.
There were two dose-limiting toxicities observed, and no maximum tolerated dose was
reached. Backfill cohorts included patients with select tumor types,
including small cell lung cancer and triple-negative breast cancer.
In addition to select biomarkers such as RB1 alterations or CDK
and two A or B loss.
On the right, you see a snapshot of some of the demographics.
The most common tumor type represented was sarcoma.
The median number of prior lines of systemic therapy was
three, and seventy-three percent of patients had one of the three
biomarkers.
The toxicity profile is shown here.
The most common side effects were nausea, fatigue, vomiting, and anemia.
Generally speaking, this was well-tolerated, with only about nine percent
having a grade three treatment-related adverse event and about four percent having
a dose reduction. There was no dose-toxicity relationship
observed.
So how does this compare to other targets when in the cell
cycle? Of course, it's difficult to compare across different
targets in different inhibitors or treatments.
But making generalizations here, it does seem like we can see some
themes emerging in terms of common toxicities in therapy targeting the cell
cycle. In particular, cytopenias, nausea, vomiting,
rash, and fatigue seem to be dominant toxicities,
and that really is consistent with what was observed here: nausea, vomiting,
fatigue, and anemia.
But there are some outstanding questions for cyclin AB inhibitors.
CID078 showed minimal toxicity observed, but
pharmacodynamic data is not yet available, confirming target engagement and
the predicted downstream effect.
How high to go remains a question. There was no MTD reached, and
there was linear PK without saturation, so they could continue to go
higher in terms of how to choose a recommended phase two dose.
Pharmacodynamics and early efficacy data will likely be important in that decision.
And there was some proof of concept efficacy reported in the presentation, but the
magnitude of efficacy, the sensitive disease types, and relevance of the
biomarkers, RB1 and CDK and two A and B for patient selection remains
unknown.
Additionally, combination therapy might be needed for clinically meaningful
efficacy. We don't have the monotherapy data yet, but we did
see from the mythic presentation earlier in this session that sometimes
combinations can be even more effective.
CID078 is a first-in-class and only-in-class agent with a creative
mechanism of action, but there may be more to come from targeting cyclin
A and B. And additional, there's space in the field for additional
molecules. So in conclusion, cell cycle dysregulation in
cancer can be leveraged therapeutically.
There's a rapidly expanding list of targets, a growing armamentarium of
drugs proposed to work through synthetic lethality, providing a potential
therapeutic index. But additional clinical data is needed to refine
biomarker selection. Thank you.
Great. Thank you so much, Dr. Schram.
So congratulations to both of you on both an excellent presentation
and putting that into context in what is clearly a
complex area. Questions from the audience,
and again, if anyone wants to post a question online, please do
so. Perhaps I might start now
with the first question,
which
alludes to some of what Dr. Schram had brought up in her
discussion. So the first question is around the dose
and around where have you finished your dose escalation,
or you're looking at exploring further doses given the toxicity
profile?
Yeah.
Great question. Thank you very much.
So we have not hit the maximum tolerated dose yet,
and therefore, dose escalation is still continuing.
But I think we're going to be
very close to picking the recommended dose for
expansion.
Yeah. Excellent. We have a question from the audience.
Yeah, I guess
the two case studies were quite exciting, but it's only
n of two that was shown, and there really wasn't a swimmer's plot or a waterfall
plot of the cohort wide of over 50 patients treated.
Can you elaborate maybe on
some of the other signals that might have been seen, some trends or the decision
maybe not to show the broader picture to the audience here?
Well, thank you for your question.
So this trial is ongoing, and given that many patients have
just been enrolled and are continuing enrollment, many of those patients
are within the first and second cycle, and I think we just don't
have the data to provide a meaningful swimmer's plot at this
point and a waterfall plot. But definitely forthcoming.
But there definitely have been other responses including in small cell lung
cancer. But hopefully at a future date, we'll be able to provide that to you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
So I'll ask one of both Dr. Delatti and Dr. Schram.
So given the complexity of this and the multiple ways of
tackling the cell cycle, what do you think are the logical combinations
to develop with the REXEL one inhibitor?
Thank you for that question as well. So I think Dr.
Schram really nicely at the end said, "Are these going to be
combination therapy drugs?" And I think that
definitely they'll play a role with combination therapy.
Thoughts are along with chemotherapy or with
antibody drug conjugates. As it comes to this particular drug, we were
really
happily surprised that we didn't see significant cytopenias, which has been
really the hallmark of cell cycle inhibitors.
So that gives us the opportunity to combine these
with other agents that may have cytopenias as combination
therapy, as opposed to seeing any form of additive toxicity there.
If you had any further question.
Over here. So what if the idea of a synthetic
lethality between the WEE1 inhibitor and the cyclin E
amplification also apply to cyclin D
amplification?
Sorry, I didn't hear the question.
Do you...
Can you repeat?
I'm sorry. Do you mind repeating the question?
Right. So the idea is if you combine the
WEE1 inhibitor with a tumor with a
cyclin E amplification, you actually push the
cell into mitotic catastrophe. So my question is,
does all the idea also apply to the cyclin D amplification?
Cyclin D.
Cyclin B.
D, like David.
D is David, yes.
D.
So earlier Dr. Yap's
presentation did discuss the cyclin E amplification, as you said, with a
WEE1 inhibitor in combination with a PKMet1 inhibitor.
We did not see any data here on cyclin D yet
today, but I think Circle Pharma actually may have a cyclin D
inhibitor that is in development.
That was not the data presented today.
So in terms of where best to place those drugs,
I think
preclinical data is ongoing, but I do as
that very busy slide I showed
suggests there is increasing interest in using
synthetic lethality when it comes to a biomarker that leads to unchecked
cell cycle progression on top of a cyclin inhibitor
that further
unchecked, I should say, cell division leading to this mitotic
catastrophe. And really the same paradigm goes for the cyclin
AB talk today, the mythic trial presented today, and a lot of
the ongoing cell cycle inhibitors. So, yes.
Maybe I'll ask one final question.
And I guess you showed us
hints of activity in two tumor types with
quite diverse biomarkers. And I guess as you're moving towards your expansion
phase of the trial, which you're not far away from, I'd like to get some
insights into how you're considering a biomarker-directed
patient selection strategy. Easy question, difficult answer-
No, definitely
... but I'd love to get your insights.
Yes.
So at this point, dose expansion is
potentially moving forward in small cell lung cancer, triple-negative
breast cancer,
certain sarcomas, leiomyosarcomas.
These are highly associated with RB alterations.
So
detecting RB alterations, loss of function
can be tricky. Many of the mutations within
the RB gene are not picked up with regular targeted
exome sequencing.
Many of the mutations are within the intronic sites
as splice site mutations. So detecting RB
alterations, one of the methods proposed moving forward
is RB immunohistochemistry, especially when combined
with cyclin D and p16 in combination can
predict RB dysfunction.
Other methods are cyclin CDK-N2A
and cyclin D transcript ratios
can also predict for RB deficiency, but really the quickest and
the easiest way that will probably predict many of them is
loss of RB by immunohistochemistry rather than looking at
the genomic sequence itself.
Well, thank you very much. We'll thank Dr. Schram and Dr.
Delatti for wonderful talks, and to you all for
being here this afternoon. And we'll, on behalf of Dr.
Desai and myself, we'll close this session. Thank you.